do you hear that kanye
bought the house right across from her
yeah i thought it was weird at first
then i was like wait it's probably just
because they have kids together yeah
yeah again that was the same thing it
was like this this [ __ ]
it was like kanye buys the hat and
everyone's like dude that's so creepy
that's so weird oh so weird he wants to
be near his kids yeah i now what is
weird is showing off new women in the
driveway did he do that i mean you know
he's just he's dating all these like
random like young models and [ __ ] and i
just feel like he's just you know
it's a bit weird just probably making
out them in the driveway for way too
long
or like opening the door and being way
too loud like all right see ya
wonderful night
get on safe
thanks for sucking my dick
yo great head by the way as she's like
leaving in the uber wonderful head you
gave me i can't believe you licked my
ass and jerked me off at the same time
have a great night you're so nasty you
freak [ __ ] i love you sick blumpkin
kim hi sorry was i oh is that being too
loud he's [ __ ] with all the windows
open he calls up an ari ari light
distributor contact he's like listen man
i need [ __ ] do you have anything that
can replicate the sun yeah man we got
tons of [ __ ] i need that in every room i
need to look like daylight in every
single one of my rooms on the second
story
everyone in kim's house kanye's doing it
again he's got a megaphone he's holding
the megaphone
moaning into it
it would sound like your construction it
wouldn't sound like what's going on
beside you
did they start road work no it's just
kanye's [ __ ] up in the second story
again is someone slapping a honey baked
ham nothing what's going on wait dude
did you know that don't look up
starliner leonardo dicaprio bought his
mom a 7.1 million dollar spanish style
house in california that was previously
owned by both modern family star jesse
tyler ferguson and gwen stefani
yeah oh you did yeah and i'm subscribed
to that account only because after i saw
that post i was like damn i need to know
more [ __ ] like this so i followed yeah
it's sick
you